the Bolivian presidential elections look
set for a second round the first time
since ever Morales searched to power
nearly 14 years ago preliminary results
show the incumbent picking up 45 percent
of the vote his nearest challenger
Carlos Meza that far behind with 38
enough for a runoff celebrated as if it
was a win itself this is a crucial point
after almost 14 long years the Bolivian
people have taken a decision in defense
of a democracy that needs to be
consolidated and renovated but president
Morales didn't accept these results as
definitive eighty-three percent of the
votes have been counted so far he
believes those still to arrive from
rural areas and give him an outright win
as always we trust the vote in the
countryside that's why we're going to
wait until the last vote has been
counted to continue with our process of
change whatever happens this election is
being seen as a setback for a man who's
used to winning by a landslide
[Music]
he did come first in this round of
voting but in the last election
he got 64% of the vote so his popularity
really has come down
Libyans are divided many like
schoolteacher Nancy are keeping faith
with the president who's almost half
poverty and kept the economy growing in
the government's before Morales there
wasn't development they had the chance
and they didn't do it but ever arrived
and made the economy grow it might not
have got to all the people but he has
tried a nephew Eric thinks differently
about the longest-standing president in
Bolivia's history we want to see a new
candidate who's going to take the
country to a better future we think that
with Evo we'll just stagnate many it's
not just a desire for change they're
also worried that Morales is slowly
eroding democracy in the country just to
run in this election
he changed the constitution and defied a
referendum in which the electorate
narrowly rejected that there could be a
weight of up to 7 days of the remaining
first-round votes to be counted and to
see if president Morales and his
followers have a fourth term to
celebrate or another electoral battle on
their hands John Holman al Jazeera La
Paz